and we're gonna give you the hard
science here's the data here are the
facts
no politics no anything
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
our first guest is tom desanto he's an
extremely popular writer
and producer known for some of the
biggest movie blockbusters
including x-men and transformers tom
will tell us more
about how he is partnering with the cdc
to challenge kids to
wear a mask as they go back to school
through the heroes wear masks challenge
and interestingly according to our
vaynermedia back to school study this
will hopefully help not only kids
but their moms who we learned from our
study are two times more fearful of
their kids going back to school
than their dads are welcome tom
thank you all very much i feel like we
are forming a
real life justice league to safety
instead of pretend we're doing it for uh
for real and hopefully we'll keep some
kids from getting sick and bringing that
home
and uh that's what we're all here for so
tom before we go into the uh back to
school stuff just for the audience
because i know a lot of um
individuals will be familiar with what
you've been involved in but maybe not
necessarily you so like
just a little back to comic book fame
actually what about a little three to
four minutes on
on comic book number one origin story
like what kind of kid were you
like going over there just
professionally for because i know a big
percentage of the audience here
uh from 18 to 81 years old have
aspirations to do things similar to you
and i think we should spend three four
minutes on that and then we'll get into
some of the other stuff got it you know
um
as gary was a baseball card kid like my
brother dan
um i was a comic book kid so first story
i have
is uh we were across the street at this
little candy store
uh in elizabeth new jersey and i was
three years old and my mom tells me i
threw myself on the ground
uh until she would buy me a flash comic
book
i couldn't even read but i think i saw
the images of the superheroes and i knew
that was my inner spirit animal
um and then from there you know i was
you know comic books
we lived in a four-room apartment we
were five people my dad was you know a
cop in new jersey
um we never you know wanted for money or
anything but we we weren't wealthy
um and comic books allowed me
and my imagination uh to leave that
four-room apartment
and to go to different universes and to
go save the planet when you're a little
kid
i think one of the things you really
want to do is make a difference
on the planet but you're small and you
don't have that that strength or that
ability
and superheroes give you that
aspirational thing um
and look if we were back in ancient
greece we'd be teaching our kids about
hercules arrogance and uh his hubris and
uh we would be telling about oh we need
to do these labors in order to learn
humility
and that's what comic books are when
they're done right these are our modern
myths
and then that's why i think it spoke to
me in that joseph campbell 101 way
and if anyone doesn't know joseph
campbell if you really want to
understand
human ability and storytelling um on why
humanity was always
asking the same questions around the
planet through their myths
even though they had no interconnection
with each other it's a great way to
take that uh college class on your own
and go look up those interviews with
bill moyers
it will give you a massive insight into
the global audience
and and and what's in people's hearts
so for me as a comic book kid you know i
remember one day
um i was also that kid rushing home from
you know football practice to play
dungeons and dragons uh
nerd it out tom let's let's let's get
everybody to understand you were nerding
out
i was nerding out and i'm living proof
that uh your action figures can become
real
and paid for many times over um
and that's you know for me you know
that's the the true success in life you
know
the one thing i would say is don't chase
money
you know money if that is your only goal
you're always going to want more you're
never going to be happy don't chase
success
success you're always going to want more
and it's the same thing but when you do
what you love and you can
find success and find financial freedom
in that
that's where you're truly a successful
person because you're enjoying
you're enjoying it instead of what it
can bring to you
yes yes being
your 80 year old self is going to be
very happy if you live that life
um what was your big break because a lot
of people ask me about breaks and
you know and and or moments or like
you know that you know just for more
another perspective another story for
the
audience i i think for me it was you
know um i was a
kid we moved from uh elizabeth new
jersey to this place of islam
um i know his one super what years were
you in island
uh i was i left island in 1994.
oh perfect so do you know the clark
uh the bradley shopping center in clark
for clark circle
my my dad's the liquor my famous story
of growing up in jersey and my dad was a
stock boy in a liquor store
was in clark circle liquor shoppers
discount liquors in that bradley's
shopping center i know exactly where
there was that they also had that video
store on the course that's right
that's exactly right so like that's like
literally like
that's that's my that's where i grew up
as that general area edison
you know 15 minute drive away i went to
high school in edison
so is that right which one yeah i went
to bishop r which is
now st thomas aquinas again so um tom my
backyard in edison was in tingly lane
and i used to play football with my
friends on
bishop bars high school field from 1982
to 1988. so that we
we literally were in that same because i
tom i'm sorry to interrupt you like just
for everybody because i know a lot of
people watching from my world
tom's high school was actually
where i put one of my lemonade stands
when i talk about my lemonade's like
literally that
that street of tingling lane yep that's
another
type of suburban area where you know
i probably bought lemonade i'm sure i
did because uh
it was uh it was that type of growing up
that well actually wait a minute you
grew up
you graduated high school when uh 86
got it 86 got it and then you moved to
94 yeah jesus christ that's crazy keep
going
yeah super small world and um you know
for
for me it was you know uh you know i had
that dream of making movies
um but it's a dream uh so i was working
uh actually at jcpenney
uh in woodbridge center i was delivering
pizzas
i was addie my first job was washing
dishes at denny's in avondale new jersey
once you have a job like that you
appreciate any
other job because that is really really
hard work
um and it's honest work um and then i
took
i started taking classes i was going to
school at rutgers and i started taking a
screenwriting class at nyu at night
so i would hop on the train i'd go in
and one of my teachers who was working
with robert nero at the time
said i was much more of a usc writer
than an nyu writer meaning that
i was much more of like a pop culture
writer than
gonna be doing taxi driver uh so i took
all of the money i had earned from that
point which was about five grand
i went to a summer film program at usc
where i got to write and direct my own
short film
and um i made my teacher cry
wow the film and that
gave me the validation that wow i can do
this
i can make someone take this in that
moment
you can get somebody into your world yes
tom i apologize for jumping in i always
get yelled at for
for uh interrupting but we have so few
minutes left and and so i want to get to
this point
give us the context because we are on
this kind of back to school moment
you've died you've gone headfirst into
an initiative for back to school
please explain that to the audience and
give some context
great so um back in february uh i'm sort
of seeing that the
medical community was having some issues
with messaging and struggling on that
front
and i really thought of what hollywood
did during world war ii
so i reached out to some friends i've
had worked in the government going back
to the clinton administration
these are lifelong public service people
and i said hey
is there anything we can do teaming up
uh and that's
i called john rogers and um he reached
out to the cdc with the cdc foundation
and we formed this partnership with
facts to health um
and our whole idea was hey let's create
a hub for people
except instead of just being hollywood
let's unlock the internet and the artist
that is in everyone around the planet
and their voices and we're going to give
you the hard science here's the data
hear the facts no politics no anything
this is how we all stay healthy this is
how we all stay safe
and this is how we all keep as normal a
life in a pandemic world as possible
because there are countries that are
killing it right now
like japan japan has 2.9 percent
unemployment they have 1200 deaths
they have uh no economic shutdown
because as a culture
since the spanish influenza in 1918 they
all
wear masks whenever they're feeling sick
and now everyone has the potential
to infect someone else i don't wear my
mask to protect myself
that protects me this much i wear my
mask to protect you
which protects you that much and that is
why we wear a mask you're not doing it
you're not appearing weak you're
appearing strong
you know you know tom you know
how difficult is it to overcome when
something gets politicized right because
i think
you know you're sitting here and saying
very nice thing it's very easy
to like from a i'm i'm very common sense
over politicization as a human so like
to me
so to me i find myself on many sides of
both
arguments yeah but but do you feel like
once something goes full till
politicization it becomes real hard
it becomes real hard but it's not
impossible and we can't give up
you know that's why it's like look no
one there is not a report
of the daily death toll of doctors and
nurses who die from wearing masks
because they overheat
yeah and by the way by the way the good
news is
like because i have arguments with my
friends i find myself
back to because i have personal views
and i can sit in
different sides on different things i
find myself having conversations with a
lot of friends
the the mask one's been easy lately with
my couple friends that are trying to
get their juices flowing on it with me
because they i think they love the
debate more than even like they
have passion for it and i said yeah no
no but but like everybody's kind of
succumbing to this one this one's kind
of like
this like the world is flat used to be a
political debate
yeah like this one's kind of i think
we're on the other side of it i'm like
razzing my buddies i'm like i think
we're on the other side of this one
but we're not ellie i'm away i'm aware
i wish we were i wish i wish i could you
know
you would agree you would agree with me
you would agree with me though in the
last 30 days
it's we're appreciative of the momentum
a little bit right
oh absolutely you know i think you know
when the president
started embracing masks when you now
start having to think about
wait a minute my nine-year-old daughter
is going to school
you know from the confines of our home
it can be politicized when your 13 year
old
is going to school and your 81 year old
mother is with you still at home
all of a sudden you might decide to put
your energy on a different political
issue
totally and look those stories are out
there you know there was a story where
somebody went to a funeral uh a couple
weeks ago uh and they brought it home
and they ended up killing someone um a
girl in her early 20s
she just wanted to go to a party i get
it i would love
us all to go back to being able to go
have a beer
and a movie and a ball game but that's
not the world we can intelligently live
in right now
and history is watching us and unless we
handle this properly they're gonna go
wow
they really screwed that up so
the number one weapon we have is wearing
a mask
washing hands and physically distancing
those are the three things we can do
um other than that see rob is leading
the way
uh rob you're gonna be the incredible
hulk in our avengers here
um so there we go see um
but honestly it's it's you know the the
best way we can keep it together going
back to school and give people as
normal a life as possible is through
this
there is no debate if you have science
that says
uh this is not effective go recheck your
facts
you know just just look at other sources
do not trust a facebook post when you
have
thousands and thousands and hundreds of
thousands of scientists and doctors and
people who devote their lives to this
saying this mask is going to help keep
people safe and you know
we're trying to prevent that story of
that that girl went to that party
and four days later she killed her
grandfather excuse me
i apologize andrea i know you're uh
you've got to bring in the next one
before we get in trouble here tom i
could speak for you
with you about bishop r and jersey and
x-men and
and mass all day and i'd like to get
connected offline i really appreciate
you being
absolutely and uh if people could just
uh
facts to health.org and uh spell that
out slowly because i know people miss it
sometimes
yes facts f-a-c-t-s the number two
and then health l-h-e-a
uh dot org o-r-g um and then do a
hashtag heroes wear masks
go to the website it has all the
information there gary and team thank
you so much stay well you got it
bye buddy hey everybody on youtube first
of all thank you so much so humbled for
your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out